now it's that's off pretty nice and
gently part 1 aparte associate all you
need to do was to do similarity now
don't forget particularly those who I
you know used to living an extension to
land and when things are similar you can
just say aah by inspection you know this
is more important here you can't skip
over these kinds of things okay so
you've got o.u.t that triangle be
similar to a WV okay so once you've
shown their equiangular you can come up
with this this ratio okay so of course
the reason for that is corresponding
science and so the travelers are in
proportion that is far away the quickest
way to say it now when you rearrange
that that gives you your expression for
capital R this thing okay see your
expression for a capital R just a bit of
rearrangement there whoops okay so
really that was the first mark for being
able to produce that and your second
mark was for using just the area of a
circle namely the area of the shadow
okay so you had to get to the area being
pi times this squared and you're
basically there okay so ah X plus D or
necks or swear and then of course your
simplify little bit and you get to the
show that done okay so that was the
second man now in part 1 part 1 there's
a fair bit of work to it right but it's
a very standard related rates question
okay um the question itself even though
it doesn't say it in the right language
it gives you the rate that you need to
work at this rate where does it give it
to you
it's right there in the end isn't it the
light source is moving horizontally
toward the coin as speed of four 70s per
second right so that means if it's
moving toward the coin well number one
which distance are we talking about
which distance is changing its X isn't
it so I've got DX on dt because good
respect to time ok is it getting bigger
or smaller it's getting smaller because
getting closer right so that's why
you've got this being negative 4 ok now
because we're after is da on dt right of
course the way that you get this is
where you've got your as a function of X
here up there right so you can
differentiate that with respect to X
after you expand everything up and what
your own multiply that by it is yes on d
team which is what you've got for us ok
so your algebra takes a little wacky but
you do get there you get it to be equal
to ah let's see here's what you get
times negative 4 and of course when you
put your value of D in there then it all
simplifies out when x equals D you get
down to this rate a whole bunch of the
DS cancel oops so there you go that's
what we were looking for there was the
second month okay so one up here for
doing the proper differentiation and the
other one for the simplification that
happens after this okay